so this video came across my path well
this one's even better than you think
okay
so this video is from anthony padilla
padala padilla padalia i don't know
whatever yeah
padilla um he's a
youtube guy so he went around and he
interviewed
a bunch of different people with this
totally real disease
uh dissociative identity disorder also
known as multiple personality disorder
by the way we the he clipped our last
thing when we talked about
what's-her-face jeff what was her name
jeff
my name is jeff yeah whatever her name
was and there's already
kyle there's already people that are
doing the same thing every time we talk
about it it's uh
pay attention it's actually real oh okay
what are you talking about
listen i know you love that girl and
everything and that's fine but
it's not real she's a liar don't worry
i've loved liars before too
there's been plenty of times in my life
i went hey bro she's got a real issue
all right man
i've met some of them and then you get
older and you go
no she's full of [ __ ] stop it so uh this
is him
interviewing a few people that have this
disease let's check it out
associative identity disorder once
called multiple personality disorder
it's a disorder in which a person
alternates between one or more alternate
personalities
that function with separate memory and
awareness and adapt with amnesia between
them
and a way of removing all consequences
and responsibility from your life
correct tell the count of the id can be
traced back to 1791
when a german woman began speaking in
perfect french and behaving like a
french aristocrat
despite never having learned french or
even that's impossible
that it's in 1791 folktale you cannot
speak a language
you haven't learned your brain doesn't
work that way
your brain how can you're
you're describing magic you're
describing math
how can you speak a language you've
never learned you would still have to
have
the origin like materials in your brain
[Music]
to to be able to use those materials of
course you can't just go like oh yeah i
just know french now even having been to
france
although appearing extremely rare to the
general public
can i ask can i ask a question what if
and i know
i know i'm speaking crazy talk but what
if
she was just a woman who taught herself
french
and was highly unsatisfied with her life
and then just decided that she could
convince people that she's somebody else
what if what if this white woman
from from 1700's germany was just being
a typical white woman
i'm if i'm just looking at occam's razor
right
it makes more sense to me that some
dopey
was just unhappy and decided to make up
a fantastic tale
and then of course back then you could
pull off a scam like that and people
would go oh my god this is the craziest
[ __ ] ever but like royce said
if you believe that she just knew french
suddenly
you're actually believing in magic
that's the best way to describe it
you're believing
it's magic and having been to france
although appearing extremely rare to the
general public
it's estimated 100 of people with
disease are youtubers
for what it's weird right so it's weird
right how how many of them are youtubers
that between one to three percent of the
global population
may have this disorder my name is
anthony padilla
and today i'm gonna be sitting there
i i first of all i hate this guy i hate
clean rob
gavigan i hate his guts he needs more
bracelets
looks like let's see if you hose down
rob yeah
close him up give him a nice cleaning
looks like rob gavigan and ryan long got
in a teleporter
and came out oh you're right one of
those star trek episodes
rob long orion gavigan yeah it's the rob
long
uh the ryan long rob gavigan tuvix
episode
that's great yeah and they're like but
dude i can't figure it out if i'm a gay
guy or a gay guy yeah but unlike tuvix i
don't care if he dies
[Laughter]
i don't know i listen man i can't figure
out if i'm a gay guy with substance
abuse issues
or a different gay guy with substance
abuse people are saying yeah figure it
out
people are saying he's half of smoosh i
don't know what smoosh is
you could keep repeating smoosh to me it
doesn't mean i'm gonna know what it is
no they they know what is smoosh i have
no idea is it
some youtube thing that i'm aware i'm
aware of no idea
he is the guy from smosh they keep
saying i don't
smosh smoosh i don't know what that is
i don't know i don't know what that is
man sorry you kids and you're smosh and
your [ __ ] capri suns
sick of it get real tight to you you
[ __ ] healies
really tired of this [ __ ] with your
soaping
[ __ ] people
anyway number one youtubers at one point
that's fine fair enough look man i gotta
tell you the youtube i watch is old
wrestling documentaries
osw an angry video game nerd that's
pretty much it so
people who dissociate into fragmented
identities to learn the truth
behind this heaven i hate this guy i
[ __ ] hate him i bet you people love
them too no i know
but you know what it's because insincere
is what people are used to now
like energetic and insincere works like
that's very
it's what young people want for some
reason and i'm like i i don't
i can i can read somebody's incense in
sincerity like immediately and this guy
is so
fake i want to strangle them
disorder does did access hidden
capabilities and skills within the brain
allowing no any questions
people to harness brain power in a way
others simply
aren't capable of or does it keep them
feeling bogged down
and restricted from participating in
normality are they
openly proud of their disorder or has
the media's productivity
forced them to live a life he's talking
you know what he is
solitude he's talking like a dude who
just did like the first three
fat rails of the night like you just sat
down and like yeah you got a little blow
and you're like yeah you guys doing some
you start breaking out some lines and he
does two big ones right away
this is that first coke rush of the
night he's like oh who knows
who knows do they have like hidden
hidden capabilities or something and
then
like are they are they pro are they
proud are they proud of this disease
and let me ask you this let me ask you
this what if we got together and we
started a talent management company
right we just got all these people they
got disassociated disorder and what what
what if we get them out there we we we
do we can make millions
i said i was uber eating hooters i asked
if you wanted something
like all right dude keep his shirt back
on [ __ ]
right this guy's done more coke than
macho man he's so
fired up man too worried of
what their presence will unleash in
others he's
he's talking the way like an
up-and-coming actor
doing hamlet but like in a community
theater in topeka
okay i hear i feel i was gonna say he
has the cadence of a slam poet
yeah like he's not doing slam poetry but
he's doing the thing that like you know
when a guy
like uh uh does it like goes to an open
mic
but he's like i do poetry he breaks out
his little notebook and he starts doing
that like
you know she she's sad so sad
because of her dad you know like when i
start
like that's what he's doing right now i
hate this guy so much i hate him
whoever found him thank you forget the
disassociated thing
please subscribe i bet you this guy's
got some [ __ ] gold on his channel
that's true we haven't even got to the
id stuff [ __ ] the ideas this guy i'm
obsessed with him
so he i spent the day with dissociative
identity disorder hi
amanda of course it's a woman oh god
oh okay
what it's the redwoods their their name
is the redwoods
that's not a name it is geographical
location
their name is the red one geographical
location i believe in california
it's susan redwoods you don't like the
redwoods
i i mean which one of her personalities
don't you like
can you go back to the glamour shot
she's cute uh could you guys that's the
idea yeah she is cute objectively the
redwoods
what
[Laughter]
why is review raw trans now review bra
or you know she looks like the chick
that just did the movie with david spade
um whatever they whatever they need the
nerdy chick in something
okay yes a little bit of corey feldman
in there too
i'll get away with it because i'm
attractive if you were a fat pig nobody
would put up with your [ __ ]
they'd be like look i don't give a [ __ ]
how many personalities you got i want
the same one coming into work every day
or you're fired okay fatty
we're coming out and teaching me about
the wondrous world of dissociative
identity disorder and to me there's so
much to learn
what do you consider yourself someone
with the identity disorder
someone with multiple alters an
attention [ __ ]
a white woman who's broken mm-hmm
you notice there's not a lot of guys
with this right well that guy
there's not a lot of men with this
disorder you notice that
like you ever notice that like you know
if a white woman murders somebody then
they'll go i have multiple personalities
there's another one ah it's
insanity like men will get arrested for
murder and they'll go
so i found out he was sleeping with my
wife and i caved his [ __ ] skull in
with a rock i found in his driveway
and a story you know like we're not
creative enough to come up with these
weird outs for things where it's like oh
it was my other evil twin personality
guys will just go yeah he was [ __ ] my
wife i went to his house i waited for
him to get home from work
i beat him to death in his driveway and
then i drove home and i'm like okay well
you're
under arrest we identify
as first as we and we identify as
multiple of course sometimes we say we
have did
sometimes we say we're plural but
multiple is the main word how much
attention do you
you know like hey rob would you
there's a there was a time in society
where you couldn't be this
you you would just die seriously
you'd be in the pile of other spartan
babies at the bottom of a [ __ ] cliff
we're too coddled like we're too as a
society now it's like we like
understand that even as recently as 100
200 years ago we lived in such an
unforgiving world
that we didn't nobody had the time to be
this
nobody had the excess time and energy to
be this way it just wasn't so
you either stopped being a we stop
thinking you're an alien and start
cutting firewood
firewood or you would be consumed by the
cold winter
that's the way it was and now we're just
indulged to the point we're like i
we prefer to be we and we are spiritual
entity it's like no you're not
who i will i'm going to assume collects
disability on some level
that we use i consider myself being part
of a did system
so you could say somebody with
dissociative identity disorder or if you
wanted to refer to us
collectively it would be saying that i'm
part of a system of alters
by the way this chick is obviously recep
where she's [ __ ] but
talk about a [ __ ] dice roll man yeah
like that's something you would talk
anybody you cared about out of that like
yeah i'm gonna go back over with this
check
no you're not no you're not that's
do not do this to yourself explain what
having did
entails yeah so having did means that
as a child your personality was unable
to weird how she's just normal here
how that just worked out she's just
normal it's it's odd to me that like for
instance you notice
kyle didn't get invited right because
people don't want to watch
well kyle's on a fly list but people
don't want to watch somebody who looks
like a 13 year old boy with a hat and a
leather jacket on in a video they got to
sex it up
they need something good for the
thumbnail so go get me the regular
disassociated girl i don't want the
[ __ ]
can't have any of the weird alts can't
have any of the dudes we need to sell
this video
so they got it all oh it's just me hello
you don't want our 50 year old pakistani
old you know what i mean like you
just notice that it's we got oh yeah we
got the the good one
sorry dave spergman in the chat jodi
arias had a healthier personality
body as a child starts off with an
unintegrated personality
and around the ages of between seven to
nine in normal development
but if there is repeated or severe
trauma before that age
then the brain can say whoa i can't deal
with this is that scientific
be my life well see what they do is just
like when they when they say like
they roll out these people one scientist
there's like one or two scientists
that'll be like no she's telling the
truth
but the medical community as a whole has
already said there's no way to prove
this you cannot do a sign
you can't do a brain scan you can't do a
scientific experiment to prove that
these people aren't just lying
yeah you can't like there's things you
can do
for other like anxiety disorders for
instance
they can put you in a [ __ ] mri
machine and try to trigger your panic
attacks
and if they trigger your panic attacks
in an mri machine you think
dude your brain just springs to like
certain areas start coming to life
the bad areas and they can actually do a
whole scan and then show you
yeah you know when we brought this up
you started breathing differently and
then look at your brain here
it turned a reddish you know what i mean
like they'll show you that there is no
did
there's no brain change like voice
there's nothing going on it's
made up and we would not be able to
survive
if i was awake i like the way she
explains it this is like your brain is
saying like whoa dude
i can't handle this is that that's
scientific success
but it's like she's talking like the
doctor from idiocracy
it's like hey man your brain is just
saying like whoa
[ __ ] dude can't do all this don't worry
my wife's tarted and she's a pilot now
lots of people are tarted living really
pitching lives now
trauma along with the ability to
dissociate to a high level
and having disorganized attachments to
your primary caregivers
prevents one personality from mike mike
lutz in the chat says anthony padilla is
a beloved youtuber
incredible actor and interviewer does it
take much for these guys to get jealous
of other success
sad who said that uh mike you left out
you forgot
yeah you forgot that part you left that
one out too um
who said that yeah mike who mike
lutz oh okay cool you know you know mike
lutz the guy who's always here always
hanging out
oh yeah the mic latch oh god yeah you
know the guy that everybody in the
community knows
they everybody went oh no man you guys
are losing mike
he's an established youth yeah nickel
band's an established band doesn't mean
i want to [ __ ] watch them play
absolutely
you know what you know that one of the
most successful pitch men in history was
jared fogle so [ __ ] eat a dick
he was beloved too at one point amnesia
that goes up to keep that trauma
away and that's why if you have did
you have multiple personalities rather
than one singular one
for us like when we first started
figuring it out
someone thought they were the only
person for like a long time right what's
the problem
that that's somebody that has no friends
that's not scott pressler
that's kind of a little scott pressler
too i am
saving black people for trump like as
most people think
with his mouth and butt i think oh i'm
just saying
i've been out here all day sucking black
dicks and telling people to vote for
trump
it's hard to forget when you see that
trump hat bobbing on your dick
people would identify with normal right
right they're like yeah of course
there's only one person right
and and you you start to think like
what could this be am i and by the way
for the record whoever said the whole
like uh
you know this guy is a beloved actor in
a youtube yeah
fake people are usually beloved like if
if you want to be one of these people
that just indulges everybody and and and
is just like yo
oh you have that i accept that answer
hey
let me bring you on and indulge you for
an hour like you know what if that's
your kind of thing
enjoy that but yes i don't know if you
realize
fake people are generally more
well-liked
because they're like hey i believe you
girl like you know what i mean like
sorry
this is either the [ __ ] [ __ ]
people are pointing out that the smosh
guy is also the guy that gave a softball
interview to susan when he interviewed
her
from youtube is he yep do you want
people to
know if that's true yeah i actually
googled uh spirit possession when it got
really strong
yeah yeah yeah fortunately this was like
2012. yeah there was some article that
was like
spirit possession versus dissociative
identity disorder and i was
you diagno okay sorry you these [ __ ]
people
diagnosed themselves and we're supposed
to [ __ ] sit here and take them
seriously
yeah we're by the way we're done
we're done culturally it's over like
there's no more
there is no everybody's allowed to
self-diagnose
and nobody else is allowed to question
anybody or hold anybody's feet to the
flames on any issue
that's the way it is now that's our
lives our lives are now
i'm living in a spirit body
and you need to accept that and it's
like uh
okay and it's like if you question me
you're a [ __ ] bigot and you will lose
your youtube channel
i was like looking at that and i went to
a therapist and they were like yep
were you were you stoked that you were
not possessed by a spirit um
i don't know somebody says he also kind
of looks like tobey maguire
a little bit do you feel comfortable
saying how many
alters you have at the last count which
was
actually about two weeks ago twenty-two
so she just keeps adding new ones
why can't you just be like every wannabe
female comedian
and call them all characters and then
suck at it that way
rob says nin was diagnosed by a doctor a
doctor in the uk
he's seen as a quack and will diagnose
you with d.i.d or just about anything
for money
we're nine people uh living in one body
so we went from three oh so it's like
the real world
except you're in one big ugly body
this is what happens when people stop
taking their medication
and start thinking to several people to
be fair there's a 44
chance the show's going to get canceled
that's this 44 every week we're going to
remove a cast member
we're going to have a series of
challenges the challenge is
don't put a in your mouth if you can
pass that challenge you get to stay in
the house
to nine yeah over like seven years
i have 16 there's 17 of us
16
and why is it like let me ask you
something if if
multiple personality disorder is
actually a real thing
then explain to me why these have like
10 personalities and they're all boring
why is it like if you have all these
weird beings living inside of you
why why aren't any of them ever
interesting do you notice that
it's just the same boring putting on
different outfits and saying that
what there's not so there's not one
personality inside of you that's like
a card shark or a pool hustler or a
[ __ ] murderer or somebody cool
why are all your personalities boring
youtubers
yeah that's a good point none of them
are awesome yeah
total do any of them do magic tricks
that's
dude even that would be cool i know can
you get the pen gillette personality for
me
or how about the teller one and shut the
[ __ ] up yeah how about that okay do you
have a personality
that's based on teller where you sit
there and don't speak
will you do all the work and get none of
the credit
it's pretty much really true
you know what though he gets half the
money that's all he does that's all that
matters
yeah a lot of gum on this one a lot of
gums
a lot of very gummy very susan looking
very gummy
all right look is this susan that might
be susan look we're gonna have to finish
this
do you have a personality that pays
people the money you want them
can we see that [ __ ] personality lady
it depends if your last name has a
precious metal in it